بالعوده الى موضوع القمه التي تعقد في
الصين وتستضيف قاده دول اسيا الوسطى هنا
في مدينه شيان افتتح الرئيس الصيني القمه
فيما ينظر اليه على انه سعي لبسط نفوذ
اقليمي لكن لماذا مدينه شيان الجواب لانها
تقع في اقصى شرق طريق الحرير الذي سيربط
الصين واوروبا عبر اسيا الوسطى اي عبر دول
المشاركه في هذه القمه وهي كازاخستان
وقرغيزيستان وطاجيكستان
واوزبكستانستان لكن هذه الدول كما نرى
كانت من جمهوريات الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
ثم باتت مجال نفوذ روسي فما الذي تفعله
الصين هناك البعض يخمن بان ان انشغال
موسكو في الحرب على اوكرانيا خلق فراغا
يحاول اخرون ملاه بينما تقول الارقام بشكل
قطعي ان الصين تن هناك بشكل ضخم في مجالات
الغاز الطبيعي والمنى التحتيه التي ستخدم
لاحقا مبادره الحزام والطريق الصينيه
البالغه قيمتها تريليون دولار والتي تعد
ابرز مشروع جيوسياسي في عهد
لنتحدث قليلا عن هذه الارقام فمثلا تؤكد
باجين ان حجم تجارتها مع الدول الخمس بلغ
70 مليار دولار في عام 2022 وسجل نموا
بنسبه
22% خلال الفصل الاول من 2023
فيما تشهد القمه جهودا لاقامه شبكات نقل
وانابيب طاقه تشمل مشروع اقامه سكك حديد
تربط بين الصين
تبلغ تكلفتها سته مليارات دولار وهذه في
بعض الارقام فقط